I'm not gonna read aloud your submitted
medical conditions when you hear yours
read please raise your hand to indicate
that it is real if you do not raise your
hand it will not be covered
what about Javed is reality you know
what you have forfeited that privilege I
have tried to treat you all as adults
but obviously I am the only adult here
number one inverted penis
could you mean vagina because if you do
I want that covered
I thought your vagina was removed during
your hysterectomy uterus is different
from a vagina I still have a vagina
okay great dermatitis Thank You Angela
I'll make sure that's covered okay now
who wrote this this hysterical one anal
fissures that's a real thing
yeah but no one here has it someone has
it
you